j'aime bien ça fait bizarre club et tous
les toits alors tu en penses quoi
mais moi je trouve bien oui mais ça va
super bien
bah oui mais partout ça doit vous avez
tous le même caractère
oui mais il est plus qu'un hiver j'ai
impression il est plus calme
donc je pense qu'il arrive à canaliser
que ma fille accepte en fait est qu'elle
pense des choses positives envers mon
mari
c'est le plus beau cadeau qu'on puisse
me et elles sont avec nous alors c'est
sylla vient toutes les semaines vous
avez vous avez laissé le cheveu oui là
je suis un maquiller un petit peu
coiffer je ressemble un très beau
paysage quotidien apparemment elle
fricote marlène schiappa celle-ci et
anissa où vous attendu à sanaa on est
très content de pouvoir
oui ma mousse et des stars du programme
toutes les deux et merci d'être là alors
est ce que vous connaissez ce programme
ou pas je connais mais j'ai pas regardé
cette saison c'est c'est incroyable bon
alors la question déjà à nice à vous est
ce que vous kiffez alain non mais
heureusement je n'ai pas compris c'est
par rapport au montage que les wings et
des réflexions et tout parce que c'était
pas passer du sto quand même sa densité
pas en lob de lui lui oui parce que la
question quant à me mettre en garde sur
ça on va revenir sur ça parce que c'est
vrai que l'avs à la fois c'est vrai que
quand il vous a vus il brasse c'est
normal il a dû dire oui elle a une
grande fille voilà me gioia qu'est ce
qui se passe c'est eu un flash et mento
men ont pas compris va surtout quand
c'est pas la culture il pas du tout non
pas du tout bas n'ont pas du tout bas
c'est normal pas du tout non mais pas du
tout
calme-toi donc pas du tout pas du tout
pas du tout du tout énoncé le montage en
fait ils ont ils ont fait un peu traîné
voilà dans la longueur
mais en fait c'est ça la rassure et
quand il a vu ma fille travaille aussi
la maman est aussi jolie que la fille
enfin voila c'est dans ce sens et pas
mal en aucun cas il ya eu un jeu de ses
buts et moi vous ira à l'un est
quelqu'un de très normal
ouais justement on en est où avec à main
là ça se passerait bien merci
comment ça arrive très bien d'accord
vous avez pu le voir ce que moi j'ai un
extrait il ya un extrait qui a fait
énormément réagir les téléspectateurs
hier c'est le comportement de cécile
avec allah lors de leurs preuves dans
leur nuit de noces
oui ça me rappelle facto avec gilles
vous étiez assez fermé à l'idée de
dormir avec lui dès le début et vous
avez tout fait pour qu'il reste à
distance dans le regarder gilles savoie
rappelle des souvenirs parce que tous
les jours
bah oui c'est vrai qu'on vous avez bien
pour les deux chinois un rappel au choix
entre deux rires oui exactement
elle met un mur c'est parti que ça
allait mieux je me pose la question
est-ce que ce soir je vais dormir dans
le même lit que mon mari comme je suis
un fossile du célibat on peut dire ça
comme ça j'ai pas l'habitude de dormir
avec
quelqu'un et gels angoisse vraiment j'ai
l'angoissé par rapport à mon physique
est relativement avantageux ou met une
petite barrière
mon côté ça septembre au tessin dans ma
tête je me demande si sérieuse quoi
s'ils savent à quoi je respecte moi quoi
moi sinon ça tricote un méritas famille
[Musique]
j'ai apprécié
de chine murail voilà mais attention la
muraille d'eau reste est imaginaire
ouais ça c'est à ça fait beaucoup réagir
à l'horizon ce que je fais dans cette
émission tout est fait pour que vous
coucher le premier soir l'accès à votre
partenaire et vous avez eu raison de
faire c'est de l'assumer c'est bien on
n'est pas là pour que je suis sûr qu en
a qui l'ont fait parce qu'il se sentait
obligé alors il faut savoir que mario
premier regard on est libre de faire ce
qu'on a envie de faire voilà s'il y en a
qui veulent consommer le mariage la
première nuit ils le font s'ils veulent
pas du tout consommer le mariage ils
vont à la prod mais absolument pas
responsables de ce qui se passe quand on
off
maintenant ma réaction je pense qu'il va
falloir que je me justifie encore une
fois parce que les gens me disent mais
pourquoi elle a fait cette émission si
elle est comme ça allait fermer tout ça
il faut aussi bien comprendre des choses
c'est que moi calme-toi celui-ci mexique
mais il faut comprendre les chaouis
cauchemar est honteux que si oui c'est
merci si je lançais réseau territoire en
fait voilà j'ai j'ai été beaucoup sur la
réserve et ce côté on peu prétentieuse
entre guillemets en fait c'est un humour
au second degré moi j'utilise mon humour
pour un peu comme un bouclier et et on
le voit quand je dis oui là patrick
timsit je vais à à douala suis un peu à
la pâte à patricia timsit
voilà mes mais voilà c'est juste une a
défendu peut-être ça voilà j'utilise
l'humour pour en tant que 20 pour un
bouclier mais c'est absolument balle je
sais que je suis loin d'être parfaite
mais je vous dire aujourd'hui on est
dans un monde où personne n'est parfait
et chassant la perfection n'existe pas
bien sûr à part castaldi la perfection
c'est vrai mais c'est vrai il y avait
pourtant il a toujours fait
l'odeur ya tué c'est sûr quitte mais moi
je trouve que cette distance allait bel
justement l'assistance parce qu'elle
prouve justement que que les deux
personnes du - madame est belle et
honnête elle veut quelque chose de
sérieux avec cette personne
donc moi je trouve ça juste magnifique
et puis on peut pas accuser la prod de
vouloir quoi que ce soit personne n'est
obligé personne n'a plus cher dans
l'entrejeu mais je n'arrive jamais à
part
voilà bernard montiel sur vidéo gag
sinon oui tiffany pardon à cécile mais
moi je trouve ça triste en fait c'est
une nuit de noces est censé être
idéalisé il se connaît très bien passé
pardon mais justement c'est bien là le
problème c'est pour ça que je trouve
navrant le concept de l'émission je
trouve ça même indécent je suis je suis
peut-être vieux jeu mais en tout cas
mais même florentin lui-même un candidat
a dit en voyant les images et en étant
là je me suis dit mais qu'est-ce que je
fais là qu'est ce que tu fais et je me
suis pris un coup de massue est lui-même
n'était pas sur ce look totalement
exactement quand ça gagnait ça jacasse
il est pas bon ça que cette voie là
moi j'assume totalement et malgré des
débuts compliqués cécile alain partent
en corse pour leur voyage de noces et la
ccil vous vous libérer un peu
complètement un ça va mais vous
commencez à être beaucoup plus tactile
avec alain regard j'ai plusieurs
facettes
afin de l'offrir tu femme je suis enfant
je suis je suis à me fie aux working
girl est bien forcé les positions de ce
maître vieux
je mourrais j'ai kiffé parce qu'il a un
humour mais moi et moi je meurs manson
humeau
avec silence on rapproche naturellement
on a des sentiments forts dans les
regards des moments très intenses très
intimiste et
c'est ce qui fait sauter ses barrières
aux flammes
je sais juste magique
je suis en train de tomber amoureuse
ça allait pas d'accord non pour la
petite emma le ramassage des buttes moi
j'appelle ma fille à ça mon bébé non je
n'appuie janet atteint je te bute avoir
au téléphone je regarde plus jamais
atterri et raccroche au nez
qu'est ce qui s'est passé à nice ça ça
vous plaît pas non mais ça ça me dérange
c'est malisan non c'est je ne sais pas
ce que ça me gêne je vois c'est
quelqu'un quoi en plus maintenant que
c'est un inconnu en fait non moi je ne
peux pas être comme ça maintenant alors
donc là son mari vous étiez énervé quand
vous avez vu ça oui ça m'a énervé d'air
je vais appeler après jour à cochonné
point fr sans doute mais en fait c'est
qui la mère et la fille dont c'est la
fille qui met des coups de pression est
là l'image est belle à l'image de maman
voilà sa maman ne doit bien sûr est
énorme alors on a ça fait des années que
je suis que maman et c'est vrai que là
ne m'a jamais vu embrasser un homme et
on pouvait pas non plus aller mal à
l'aise en fait ah ouais oui mais matic
malgré tout pourquoi pas parce qu'elle a
du mal à se voir embrasser son mari soit
disant et safia dimanche sa part au
convoi rhissa vous pensez que votre
maman l'embrasserai plus jamais aucun
homme bassila prêt en temps réel de la
demande 3 millions de personnes ça me
gêne un peu quand même
ce jour montrent plus les ordures si on
voit votre maman
alors vous avez mis un petit peu l'art
au stade l'émission sur les réseaux tout
le monde dit que tu ferais une candidate
parfaite pour la téléralité autre chose
et tout est parti de l'essayage de la
robe de ta mère où tu as eu des mots un
peu durs on va revoir ça non ça c'est
pas ça tu comprends pourquoi tu fais ça
en fait avoir mais que tu connais pas la
mairie comme ça la cepam et adjointe au
bout d'un an je suis pas du tout
ajustement j'ai 40 ans mais justement
[Musique]
cécile a réussi à convaincre sa fille de
l'accompagner aux essayages de sa robe
de mariée à l'ego c'est parti
moi je trouve que ça fait bouffer un peu
enfin 2 3 kg en moi ça serait pas de
refus quoi c'est pour son bien quoi pour
pas que son futur mari dix hommes
cruz mais là c'est gênant que la prod et
est choisie parce que je sais que c'est
pas vous qui avez choisi cette robe là
non pour le coup ça c'est pas voilà ça
ça me dire oui mais bon c'est pas grave
ouais mais bon anissa est ce que vous
étiez contente quand votre maman vous a
dit je vais faire cette émission
ah non pas du tout bad est toujours quoi
un genre je suis à fouka voilà qu est-ce
que j'ai une faim si je les avais pas en
fait que ce que vous avez envie que
votre maman feront face à 10 quand même
oui quand-même mouais ça radio ou froids
masisi qua non non je le sens pas non
mais une crosse c'est pas grave puisque
allemande en a plein 5 et non mais si
bas après vous bien car de façon bien à
sa vie un jour ou l'autre mais pas la
sat principe là ça vous plaisait pas
l'abonnement pas trou comme mais vous
avez qui s'était un peu brutale quand
même mais à mes séries que vous êtes
devenu l'art au stade l'émission est ce
que ça vous plaît ou es ce que vous avez
ça je ne me sens pas coûte rien au foot
c'est pas l'art au stade l'émission mais
non c'est pas ça
si saint pie x dont elle est l effet une
formation à l'est puis à l'école
d'accord alors anissa est ce que toi tu
es contente que ta maman et trouver
l'amour m'a bien sûr bien sûr parce
qu'elle reçoit
c'est toujours sacrifié pour moi et est
maintenant qu elle a pris son envol ben
ça me fait plaisir mais rj patafil
maintenant que vous connaissez alain
est-ce que vous l'appréciez est ce que
vous comprenez le gothard c'est vraiment
quelqu'un de cool franchement si j'aime
toujours les troupes
j'apprécie beaucoup cette tombe au père
allant donc ça veut dire que vous n'êtes
pas un indice à a
je la sens pas cette affaire hanouna il
a le pis que vous le dis je la sens pas
cette affaire moi je sens que je dis ce
que je ressens je pense qu'alain vous le
considérait plus comme un m je sens que
c'est vraiment une amitié qui va durer
énormément d'humour
oui alors moi j'adore ça en fait ce qui
ressort beaucoup de l'épisode d'hier
je suis constamment en train de rigoler
et lui aussi c'est vrai que moi mais
justement en amour on va me qu'à moitié
dans son lit on peut être
ni amant papa voilà un couple c'est ça
et alain lefrançois ur de malades et et
moi j'adore je craque pour moi j'adore
alain ouais alors franchement je le
kiffe non mais vraiment sûrs a dit moi
je trouve que ce qui est très fort et
c'est pour ça on a dit qu'on s'identifie
à vous à toutes les deux c'est que vous
c'est la bridget jones et la crise de la
quarantaine c'est à dire que vous avez
parfait votre vie vous êtes mal dans
votre peau
alors que vous êtes subi mais vous avez
tout perdre ou non mais voilà vous avez
la voilà à trouver un habitat est en
fait moi je trouve qu'il ya un pouvoir
d'identification comme le disait kelly
vous êtes hyper touchante hyper sincère
hyper fragile
on a envie de vous aimez et vous pour
moi c'est l'ado c'est à dire c'est
vraiment ça donc en fait vous jugé votre
maman comme tous les ados c'est pour ça
que ça marche bien à votre binôme et que
c'est hyper juste parce qu'en fait c'est
vraiment des sans fil 3 2
on est vraiment sensible il faut savoir
alors si je peux me permettre aussi je
suis là ici alors je vais avoir beaucoup
de messages de machin oui a fait le buzz
et tout moi je m'en fous complètement je
crains vraiment bien bien dans ma dans
la grille sont fiables dans vos métiers
si je suis bien dans ma vie je suis
vraiment heureuse juste ici en fait je
suis venu aussi là ce soir pour je sais
que c'est un fléau entre guillemets de
2021 et même de cette génération qu'on a
il ya énormément de personnes de 40 ans
qui sont seules avec des enfants ils
nous interdisent de se reconstruire en
tant que femme je reçois énormément de
messages là dessus donc et même à
regarder bernard si je peux laisser un
jeu si je peux envoyer un message pour
ces femmes-là qui elles sont quand je
dis sacrifier moi je dis que c'est
vraiment un sacré que j'ai fait mon rôle
de maman mais plus plus plus plus plus
on a eu un parcours très très très très
difficile avec anissa grâce à dieu ça se
passe beaucoup mieux mais si je peux
envoyer un message à toutes ces
personnes qui espèrent rencontrer un
jour quelqu'un me voilà qui ont eu 2 qui
va avoir une deuxième chance et être
voilà ne pas qu'être maman je suis là tu
là je suis là pour ça ce soir et en
aucun cas c'est pour me montrer machin
même si vous ne connaissez cette
émission pas oui je connaissais c'était
bien tu as bien fait c'est marrant
franchement c'est incroyable amoureux
c'est
moi j'ai personnellement je n'oserais
pas le ferai mais franchement je vous
dis franchement je lâcherai rien à
perdre j'ai tout gagné a vraiment mais
humainement parlant si une expérience de
vous avez maintenant et non servir ma
fille non ça nous a rapprochés voyez ces
moments là c'est on ne vivra jamais une
deuxième fois sa vasque en son nom enfin
elle va revenir la prochaine semaine
prochaine avec alain d'accord avec un
sais pas si vous avez envie de faire de
la télé ou pas non pas parce que tout le
monde dit la télé réalité en tout cas
d'accord vous avez pas ouais t'as envie
de faire quoi plus tard joseba premier
coeur avec nous non mais tout le monde
vous adorent en tout cas c'est vrai oui
ou non
à nice elle a eu un coup de coeur pour
un indice à toutes les régates sourire
moi tu reçois ministre ou non mais faut
aussi mais c'est la route derrière moi
même mais pas du tout on adore votre
fille annie ça on vous adore et on adore
votre meilleur ami allende pour venir
vous revenez à la télé réalité on a
évidemment je pense que voilà c'est pas
une fin en soi en 2021 c'est vrai que
mon voisin gaming un peu jauni osaka le
gala télé réalité mais j'ai pas vu voilà
18 19 ans est pas une fin en soi en fait
la télé rhénan mais bon après voilà ma
fille moi en tout cas je ne m'opposerai
pourquoi parce que d'abord foca sur
construisent en tant qu'adulte les
jeunes filles de 20 ans 22 ans qui sont
balancés là dedans j'ai rien contre elle
mais perso je n'aspire pas à cet avenir
pour ma fille faute d'avoir gagné
surtout fâché rien dit oui parce que je
vois beaucoup sur les réseaux sociaux
avaient mangé tous à la société dé la
téléralité fera pas les ans le fera la
mission numéro un c'est des marseillais
voilà
on ne va pas faire les ongles un nom il
faut faire vite on fait quelque chose
sauf à la 8e elle va faire un métier un
vrai mais des tables en tout cas parce
qu'elles soient non mais c'est bon merci
à 10h du caniche à ce que tu es fier de
ta maman bas bien sûr moins cher demain
non tu es heureuse pour aller à la selle
beau-père que tu voulais être isolé bah
oui c'est oui c'est beau père que je
voulais oui mon père de wisches il
espère me glisse voilà son papa oui pas
moi en tout cas là moi je trouve qu'il a
beaucoup beaucoup de qualités et
j'espère qu'il était à quelqu'un